now let's have a look when we start to
add some conditions on this okay so Part
B what what condition is it give us how
many different routes are possible if
you must pass through West see where is
it it's for every minute okay here we go
sort of diagonal there we go like that
so EC is okay so if I want to pass
through C then I've got to go from A to
what you see I can't do this blue one
yeah this blue one is a dud it's no good
the black ones okay though it passes
through C so in other words you've got
to go from A to C first because I don't
think you can backtrack can you you
can't sort of climb back up okay so
you've got to get from A to C and that's
kind of like its own mini problem isn't
it from A to C right so if that's all
you had to do pads from A to C what are
you going to how how do you get from A
to C how many rightward steps do you
have to do two of them right how many
downward steps you have to do two so you
can either think of it as four factorial
on 2 factorial 3 factorial or you can
think of it as you've got four steps and
you've got to choose two of them to be
downward steps right which gives you the
other ones that are right with okay
that's how to get to see what about from
getting to see to be how many steps in
total right and downward do you have to
make to get from C to B have a look I
count one two three four five six steps
that should make sense because
originally for the whole problem we said
ten steps and we've already done four of
them to get to see does that make sense
so I've got six left and I've got to
choose well I've got to choose two of
those steps to be right steps don't I
it doesn't matter which ones they are so
6 C 2 or you could just 64 if you like
because that will be the same number
okay so I have two numbers what am I
going to do with these numbers
am I gonna add them or am I gonna
multiply them are you sick of me
answering asking this question yet I'm
going to multiply why am I going to
multiply yeah this is all together I
don't just want to land on C I want
to also go to be these have to go sort
of simultaneously right so my total pads
I should write total that might be
helpful total piles will be 4 C 2 by 6 C
2 what what is that equal to is that 90
it's nice right there you go
happy times okay yeah did I get ya no
yes okay great
it must be six times 15 is my guess yeah
cuz that's the middle of anyway okay you
get the point right now it starts to get
interesting because questions seeing
question do have this interesting
relationship you which you might have
noticed if you've already um picked at
the answers so let's have a look at it
together right how many different routes
are possible if you cannot move along
the top line of the grid if you cannot
move along the top line of the grid so
what are they saying right well what
they're doing is they're transforming
this problem a little bit I'm gonna get
rid of this orange stuff cuz not
relevant anymore I'm not allowed to go
along the top so it's as if this top row
doesn't exist right you're banned from
going there is that okay now as you can
see if the top row doesn't exist anymore
then I've got a whole bunch of other
steps that I also cannot use right which
um or all liens paths right which ones
can't I use if you can't use any of
these top ones how are you for example
how are you going to get to this line to
use it well you can't get there to begin
with
right you can't go along and then sort
of climb up right you have to come from
the top does that make sense so in
removing the top row is one of the
options you've also removed these guys
does that make sense you see how we've
transformed the problem okay now and is
it going to sound a bit trivial but it's
a an important question this point here
right I have to pass through there do
you see that like that's the only way to
go let's call that my new C as it were
how many ways is not a rhetorical
question how many ways are there to get
to see in this new situation there is
just one way right one way right and
then I have to get from C to B well how
many total steps will it take me to get
from C to B it'll be nine right one less
then I had before I've already taken
care of one of them nine and you've got
to choose or you can either do four or
five doesn't matter I've got to choose
four of those nine steps to be a
rightward step yeah because there will
be still one two three four to the right
that I have to do like so is that all
right I don't know what that's equal to
because how much I'm gonna take it
126 okay now when we do Part D okay it
sounds similar but different how many
different routes are possible if you
cannot move along the second row from
the top of the grid okay now here's what
I'm gonna do I am going to draw this
diagram again and maybe you want to do
this as well the diagrams are so helpful
I'm gonna draw this diagram again but
then I'm going to try and see what this
condition looks like on the new diagram
so I've got one two three oh how many do
I have one two three four there we go um
can someone count is that the right
number of everything does it look okay
happy yes okay so it says how many
different routes are possible if you
cannot move along the second row now to
deal with plant seed remember what I did
before I just removed the rows the the
lines you couldn't use right I'm gonna
do the same thing here okay
the second row is along here yes do you
see it so I'm going to eliminate the
second row as a credible option right so
watch like that like that and like that
like that okay so I've removed the
second row are you happy with that
with me having done that okay now when I
removed the top row in the previous
question I also had to remove some other
lines that sort of led from the top row
do I have to remove any other lines at
this point are you happy with that
that's okay so for example what that
means is if for instance I was here and
moved down and did that step right I
can't use the second row can I right so
I have to do this step there's no other
choice right in other words there's only
one way to get from like it's actually
one move even though in the original
scheme it's two does this make sense
okay now have a look at this new diagram
is the agreed right
it has this top row that's like twice
the height of all the other rows but in
terms of the number of steps it is it's
only one step right so now tell me in
this new grid how many steps does it
take to get from A to B you can count
the right here 1 2 3 4 right with steps
at any different point they don't have
to be along the top obviously for
rightward steps and how many downward
simple you can count them right 1 2 3 4
5 why are there only 5 and not 6 I got
rid of a row right it's gone so that's
why this up here it functions like a
single row of boxes even though it used
to be two okay so therefore that's why I
can say well the number of parts is just
like what we did in Part C you've got 9
total steps and you've got to choose 4
of them to be rightward steps or if you
like you've got to choose 5 of them to
be in downward steps right it used to be
6 but now it's 5 because this which
looked like a double root before it's
just one move now that's the only way
you can go it's the only possible path
ok so that's why when you go into the
solutions and if you get mystified
you're like why are these two equal
because you can retell the story so they
are the same problem okay just to rewind
right to the beginning probably the
hardest part of this was looking at this
geometric problem and turning it into a
word problem we're quite good at these
ones right rearranging letters of words
ok if you can come up with a way to
state whatever problem you've got in
these terms then you can use all the
tools and knowledge that you already
have does that make sense